foreign
oh
my God
people
foreign
let's go live okay we're live
okay this is the Lamy Pico I was talking
about so it's like um but then you click
it okay and it expands very exciting I
thought it was a vape that's very yeah
yeah
that is a little yeah a little
switchblade pen yeah and then yeah it'll
expand it is this may be my favorite pin
ever that I've ever gotten
and it's the most expensive pen I've
ever gotten but I went to a pen store uh
on my way up I did some shows in North
Carolina and Virginia this week in
Greenville has a great pin store that
I've wanted to go to and then the guy
got me on that one
never met a fellow pen nerd this is very
exciting oh dude go down a pinhole pin
shopping thing or something yeah I could
go um and I got another one this one
like it has it has like the clip on it
and then you like click it and then the
clip will disappear
when you're riding with it and then
it'll come back up I wasn't ready for my
pin Show and Tell absolutely no you're
good
next time I'll have my pins ready to go
no problem I think you just said you
lost a Mont Blanc and then my heart I
did I didn't lose it it's just lost in
the apartment somewhere it's like we
moved from New York City to La about two
years ago and uh most of it is organized
but you know I'm kind of one of those
those people that like put stuff
everywhere so it's here in the house it
might be in you know the closet or
something I'm gonna find it that's gonna
be my goal and I'm gonna let you know
I'm gonna find it we're gonna hold the
whole thing dude you gotta let me know
I'm gonna let you know we're gonna find
it I feel like after this show I'm gonna
just tear the apartment up again and
find it
but yeah I could do a whole podcast just
on about pins
or Comics though so it's like that's our
guitar you know yeah that's true yeah
yeah I mean mics like I have you know
like cool
yeah yeah yeah bikes and mics and pins
you got a fancy mic like mics and pens
that's really all we got maybe stools I
guess how funny would that be just
showed up with your own stool
it's like studded up and leather on it
you're like yeah this is a stool I use
for my water and you just put it on
stage yeah a contest I won a few years
ago one of the prizes was a stool
I never got one but oh yeah no they
never hooked me up with one it was
supposed to be like a custom stool but
it would have just taken up room so it
was fine
yeah I don't know man I mean see Comics
always get the shaft I think you should
really follow up on that it's the idea
that they didn't pay you you know what I
mean it's not about the stool it's like
they said they were gonna give you that
in payment that's you know what I mean
you know that's very valid either so
I'll have to follow up
oh and uh John Mondragon said let's put
a pin in that okay so I guess that's
enough
and talk everybody there we go and um
let him tell her when you need them
more pen stuff I could do come on the
joke with pinpoint accuracy over here
leaking all over the place
let's bring Anna let's bring on my
co-host Yoshi he he always joins fresh
off of family he leaves his family to
this show every week so we're here
what's going on how are you brother yeah
buddy I'm good it's exciting
yeah good to see you I don't think your
mic is used I think your your microphone
is your microphone on Yoshi
this one all of a sudden stopped working
the the fancy one so I think I'm using
just the one attached to like the camera
yeah you get a pretty terrible
microphone
I mean you know I mean compared to
Dustin and I you know you know we care
more than you just so you can care a
little bit more
but the quality we put out into the
world yes whatever I don't you know
you would care more but it's just me so
nobody cares I get it
I gotta do movies I can see no man get
respect around here I get it what are we
doing did we start what's happening yeah
we've started we've started now that
we're established that Yoshi's audio
will be what it is
[Laughter]
no it's all good we appreciate you
sneaking in here Yoshi so um as always
nope no worries at all
this is going to be a good one here I'm
super jazzed about this one here
super jazzed we have Mr Dustin Chaffin
here you said it right good work
my guy
what's up I do my research former
uh Mormon
viewer and yes
then you just filmed
uh your dry bar special in the Mormon
state of Utah so caboose
Provo Utah the comedy Mecca and uh
who knew oh wow all right sound effect
did we just lose Yoshi I think we did
and then but but he got an Applause
break on the way out so
leave them laughing
for room
so yeah there's a there's a few things
um I definitely want to get into the
Weeds on but I think the first thing is
just your dry bar
your whole dry bar experience like how
you booked it
um when you I mean I filmed one almost
probably a year and a half ago now so it
hasn't been out yet so uh but my whole
experience was positive and I loved
every second of it but how how was yours
how did you book it maybe like talk
about it from like the perspective of
like a comic who maybe aspires to get
one someday kind of take us through that
whole deal
sure
um well a lot of things first of all the
um the Mormon angle is interesting
because it was like uh I went through a
Mormon stage and I got girl in high
school that whole thing and um you know
the last time I was in Provo Utah was at
the Missionary Training Center and
that's where they train you how to like
speak Spanish I went to Chile and how to
speak Spanish and like manipulate people
and to believe in the Book of Mormon and
all that stuff it's like this training
center and it's in Provo just kidding
all my Mormon people I love you I know
it's it's whatever anyway so I did that
in Provo like that's where it was and so
the idea of coming back and being like
this you know kind of Rogue you know
Wild Man comic and then I'm you know
filming my comedy there I mean I went
from you know an elder to a stand-up and
then I'm doing my special there so that
was really really fun to be in front of
like you know the Provo crowd and I knew
a lot of inside stuff so you know I I
would throw in some Mormon things and
you know all that stuff so that was fun
to do but I had worked with TJ Miller at
um Wise Guys in Salt Lake City I don't
know are you still there let's see it
looks like you yeah you uh oh I went off
okay no you're there I'm it's just all
me
yeah
we got we got
this is going great
would you think you're better than Zoom
you get some app that's just just going
you know you're gonna kept it simple it
just did Regular Zoom paid the 19 bucks
a month anyway so um so yeah so I
performed with TJ I was doing uh that
club Salt Lake City uh and Wise Guys and
you know I think in comedy um I've
gotten better at in probably the past
couple of years that I moved to LA and
stuff and asking for things and I feel
like a lot of times as Comics it's like
I don't know how it was with your
experience getting the special and stuff
but a lot of times you know we feel like
you know it's like you don't want to be
that guy you don't want to be annoying
you don't want to you know you want to
make you don't want to mess up a
relationship because you asked for
something at the wrong time and all that
stuff so it was kind of one of those
things I had a pretty good weekend I
didn't like my sets I don't know if you
have those experiences where people
think you do Well everybody's like that
was awesome but in your head you're like
I didn't like that set but
um and and I did the first show I did
all clean first and and but it's Salt
Lake nobody cares nobody asked me to be
clean I just thought in my head that I
had to because you know the Mormon
Temple's so close so I was like I guess
I'll you know be clean so that was a set
he watched he didn't watch any of my
other sets where I was kind of filthy
and so the guy that was that runs the
club kind of saw that set and then
didn't really watch too many of the
other sets but I did well enough that
you know he he just that when I I asked
him I was like hey you know I know you
do these dry bars and stuff I'd like to
submit a clean set for it whatever and
he was like what are you doing you know
in April in May on a Saturday whatever
and he was like literally booked me
right there so it was kind of one of
those kind of crazy experiences where
you know I asked and then you know I
kind of received it and it was just like
instead of the run around of email and
all that so it was great and uh but yeah
but it was one of those opportunities
where I knew that you know he saw I
could do what I could do and you know I
could keep it relatively clean but but
yeah so that's kind of how I got that it
just opened my mouth which I think a lot
of comics would get insecure about it
and or we ask too much there's that guy
because I used to run a comedy club I've
ran a few comedy clubs and uh you know
Comics have very bad etiquette in
knowing when to ask somebody for
something you know I feel like uh we
could go in on questions on this all day
but uh yeah you ran the Boston comedy
club didn't you I ran to Boston for a
little while the last couple of years uh
when it meant something you know it was
just like Chappelle and uh you know all
those guys now when it turned into
comedy those I don't know what that was
but uh yeah I ran it what is a big deal
Patrice all those guys Greg Geraldo Bill
Burr they all came through and before
they were getting a whole lot of love at
the cellar they were getting loved there
and you know I would get to work with
these guys and stuff so yeah I've been
on both ends of it for a really long
time
yeah that was the legendary Boston
Comedy Club I think with Barry did Barry
cats own it okay we're live Barry Katz
yes Barry cats okay he uh
now my old audio is coming back I don't
know what's happening oh yeah Barry cats
uh yeah he ran it which it was such a
weird thing because it was like it was
you know it was about this scene in
Boston which was great and he opened it
up in New York on West Third uh right in
the heart of Greenwich Village and it
said Boston Comedy Club so basically all
it would happen the entire night every
night we were there some Yankees fans
just be like bastard sucks
flipping us off and making it some
Boston New York thing we're like no dude
it's about a scene of Comedy like we're
not like you know just so funny that
like it just angered New York guys that
you know that it was you know not the
Boston Red Sox comedy club or whatever
but you did walk in they did have all
that stuff on the wall which was kind of
disrespectful they would have all the
you know Boston Red Sox stuff everywhere
so it was kind of a Fu to people but
anyway but yeah it was a cool club man
it was like that's where I it was kind
of like my comedy University you know
it's like you got I got to watch you
know amazing guys you know Louie and all
these guys guys just kind of find it on
stage when they weren't famous yet and
stuff and so you know I feel like it was
it was a great time to get to know like
watch like a Marc Maron you know figure
it out and things like that was just
really the best learning experience you
could have as a comic I always tell
people if you're a brand new comic and
you walk into a comedy club go watch the
show because that's where you're gonna
you know that's where you're gonna learn
that you're gonna see and that's what
you know that's what was great about
just being able to watch all these guys
I feel a lot of young guys are more
concerned about getting their spots
instead of like learning from the vets
that are playing the club I see that a
lot you know what I mean like so where
somebody comes in and they just kind of
want to be like hey can I get a what how
about you just watch the show for a
little why don't you learn and sit back
so we got to sit back and watch these
great guys and watch crazy experiences I
remember one time Kevin Hart was on
stage and Patrice O'Neal was in the back
and this is how this is how old I am
this we used to have these same kids
called phone books
they would send these things these big
yellow things called phone books and
they would send them to places and you
if you wanted information you had to
open this book and so I remember there
was a stack of them at the club and
Patrice O'Neill was in the back and
Kevin Hart was on stage probably like 15
people in the audience and he was
throwing phone books on the stage going
I can't see you get on these phone books
and he was like throwing phone books
across the room onto the stage and poor
little Kevin Hart like just trying to
you know not get hit by these phone
books so that's the kind of that's the
kind of stuff that was happening there
because it's kind of a very cbgbies of
Comedy kind of thing
yeah do when you mentioned young comic
mistakes and you've seen so many like
and I know you you will also like do
some comedy coaching and mentoring for
Comedians and stuff what are some of
like the most common comedian mistakes
that you've seen over your career
I mean and I've made a thousand of them
um yeah of course we all know of course
yeah yeah um
speak for yourself okay for yourself
Yoshi's never made a mistake that's why
I can't turn this microphone on anyway
um so he knows everything but uh
I think there's a lot I mean you know
being too drunk at a comedy club you
know that's that's a big one you know
I'm a big sober guy and as I made a lot
of mistakes you know you're just talking
[__] and just going on stage too drunk
or too high like that's a big one you
know it's like just because you can
doesn't mean you should you know look
I'm funny when I'm high or whatever so I
think that's one just being kind of
messed up and not yourself 100 you know
it was a big one and uh you know
bothering people when it's not a good
time to bother people you know if you
see somebody like you know like a
Saturday night 10 o'clock they're trying
to start the show probably not the best
time to go up to the people and ask for
a spot like you know just finding like
you know timing is everything off stage
as well you know I just you know
somebody's like trying to get the show
going you gotta somebody complaining the
manager whatever and then they'll go up
and go hey could I get it you know it's
like that kind of stuff timing knowing
when and kind of read the room you know
when it's busy at a comedy club but uh
yeah I don't know and then just being
ready for it when you do get your shot
you know there's don't be delusional
like you know there's a lot of
delusional comedians you know I mean I
call it open mics but there's a lot you
know where it's like you
yeah you just like you have no clue
where you're at like I'm overly where
I'm at David Taylor gets off stage first
thing he says hey was that okay
meanwhile he just destroyed like there's
so many self-aware great comics and then
you see this kid these young guys with
attitudes and they just they're not
aware what killing means you know if
they're not standing on their feet then
you didn't really kill you know what I
mean like to me that's you know what I
mean like I don't know there's don't
throw that word around so be so just
know where you're at I guess is what I'm
trying to say before you ask for
something because you only get so many
shots when you ask so I don't know
that's just a few you might have some
too I don't know what's what are some
that you feel but that was really funny
you mentioned not killing on stage
thinking they did is like that's an
exact example that Nate gave when he was
on here about like a comic was giving
all this advice in the green room and he
goes up in bombs and then comes back off
like see that's exactly how you do it
he's like he bombed but he had no idea
in his head
great yeah yeah no clue even a vet yeah
even vets are like that yeah it's not
just the young guys for sure yeah
there's a lot of these guys you know
but uh that's funny that Nate would say
yeah cause Nate was there with me like
we were doing all that together you know
it's like we're seeing all those you
know funny moments but yeah Comics you
know I don't know I think if you if you
have any gift at this I think you kind
of know where you're at
but when you think you figured out I
guess
you know you've been doing this for some
time now
uh and you've been in a lot of different
scenes when do you think you figure out
okay this is something that I can take
to like
full-timeness or like be like a
profession
um you know I always try to figure out
what was the best situation you know for
me as a comedian even like off stage in
lifestyle you know it's like uh you know
I made sure that I lived with three
other comedians so I could afford to not
have a real job I think that was the
first thing that was important you know
I found a situation we lived all lived
in Astoria it was like you know four
Comics living together so it's like I
put myself in a situation so I could
kind of like make a living at it and I
think what's you know once you stop
asking mom for money I guess you start
to feel like a comic
it's like once you once you can say all
right that uh you know that Firehouse
gig paid for you know my rent and my you
know whatever
VFW that weird Elk Lodge show you know
like whatever the soccer benefit all
that weird stuff Camp shows all this
stuff I think once you start kind of
just you know basically making a living
but uh but I think it's more than that I
think you know I think TV is important I
think it's important to kind of like
have something that you strive for and
once you get that I think it's like a
lot of you know because I think now
people feel like they don't need TV
because of tick tock and social media
and all that stuff so I don't know I
always felt it was important to kind of
have big goals and
um you know and say all right you know I
mean I wasn't like a late night my first
TV thing was a weird one Yoshi it was uh
Showtime white boys in the hood it was
uh
you couldn't do that show now
it would cancel you pretty quick
it was like Eminem comedians dude it was
hilarious and it was like
well it was white Comics a lot of white
comments doing black jokes in front of
black crowds and it was but a lot of us
came
Uptown comedy shows and urban Latino
nights and so we knew how to work those
crowds and so that's kind of how the
show kind of came together because a lot
of us came up through all those kind of
shows and so you know it kind of formed
into this thing but uh but yeah I mean
once I did that it was kind of you know
I could say I was on TV
it's show time don't worry about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think it's kind of
funny I like it I like watching a host
say it though you know
all right uh who's next guys Showtime
white boys with a Z yeah yeah
like a DJ white boy
he let me show up with that hat yeah
well I kind of dressed like a brother so
it's you know but it works but yeah I
think the TV credit was big I think once
I got that and then it started you know
just kind of I don't know just figuring
it out you know hustling and figuring
out how to make a living and you know
and that's the thing over the years I
always felt like as long as I was doing
something in stand up then I was happy
you know if sometimes you could do full
tours and you're working on the road all
the time sometimes you know you got a
coach or sometimes you gotta run a show
or whatever but as long I feel like as
long as stand-up was part of the whole
thing then I was okay with it so because
I was a hustler like that you know it's
like I'll do whatever it takes I was
like the P Diddy a comment I was a dude
whatever man I'll do whatever white boys
you know yeah
whatever it took I would just do
everything so you know but I don't know
I just love being a part of stand up no
matter what capacity it was
yeah Victoria said Dustin is the best
comedy coach oh okay all right Victoria
yay Victoria she's great she's uh yeah
she's very passionate you know about
stand up and wants to get better and
better and that's that's one thing about
love about working with Victoria it's
like she really wants to get better I
think some Comics they just kind of set
on it you know just because you get
laughs doesn't mean you know like she
really works hard so yeah thanks
Victoria I appreciate it been great
working with you yeah and I also feel
like because we've done so many
interviews on here that I also feel like
sometimes people listen to this show
and don't like take action they don't
like or like they're like oh I'm waiting
for the right time to get on stage or
I'm waiting for this moment to try this
new joke or whatnot but like at the end
of the day like you can take classes you
can get coaching you can listen to the
podcast but at some I mean at some point
you gotta get on stage and you've
actually gotta put the work into action
that's how you're really Gonna Know
yeah uh Joel how did you get on stage
what was your first like how did you
like did you work at a club or like no I
was yeah I did an open mic at a comedy
club by my college yeah okay
and then how did you start to get stage
time though like how did you just I did
I was about to graduate from college and
then I tried that open mic and then I
was hooked from then on so they did like
two open mics a month so I did both of
those one I paid one of them was a paid
Open Mic so I would like pay for the
stage time to hate myself and then I
moved back to Atlanta and then just got
on stage anywhere and everywhere because
every advice I had ever heard in my
research and then since interviewing so
many commands the advice is you got to
get on stage so I just yeah in Atlanta I
was just on stage every single night or
if I wasn't performing I was there like
in a comedy club watching the headliner
that weekend I love it I love it yeah my
first uh my first stand-up experience
was at a college was uh BYU Idaho which
was kind of the second tier to BYU uh
Salt Lake or Provo or wherever it is and
so it's like it's those of us who
couldn't get into the Utah BYU they
shipped us all to Idaho
so we could get our grades up and get
married and go to the other one
yeah but I did a talent show in uh at
this BYU Idaho it's actually called
Rick's college but it was a Mormon thing
whatever and um now it's BYU Idaho but
anyway and I did a Mormon I did a talent
show and I and I crushed it I got a
standing ovation and it was like I I
don't think I've had a set that good
since I've been chasing that high yeah
I've had a few standing O's man this was
like unbelievable and I was like ah so
that was the first time I did stand up
and then you know I felt like it's just
something about a college crowd that you
know people and stuff that's a good
that's a good good way to go in
sometimes
but uh yeah I worked at a comedy club
for you know like when I first started I
hated open mics I felt like I couldn't
get any rhythm off of it like it just I
couldn't so I just worked you know at
like just handing out flyers or cooking
or cleaning the toilets whatever it took
you know I just wanted that five minutes
whatever it took yeah it's like I was a
busboy and all that stuff at the New
York comedy club on 20 when it was on
24th Street with Al Martin that's where
I first started I was a you know I would
I was a busboy Anna Cook which I don't
think is legal in New York City you're
not supposed to clean the toilet and
then work the fry machine but what he
did
but comedy is so like ridiculous anyway
like nobody's checking in on us that
much but uh yeah
yeah I was yeah and then one time I
gotta I remember the the the New York
comedy club I don't know you guys know
it right you've been there I've heard of
it I haven't been there though oh okay
okay well they have a uh there was a we
did some remodeling in it and there was
like a stove that we couldn't move we
couldn't remove it from the club so they
just put up sheetrock so right if you go
when you go to the New York comedy club
there's a stove that's where the
headshots it's on both there's like a
wall it's walled in where the headshots
are and it's a freaking stove in there
that's been dirty since 1983. so
somebody one day somebody's gonna break
that wall and it's gonna be like a tomb
in there and be like
but yeah it's gross but uh yeah so one
time I was uh dropping mozzarella sticks
and I was doing a shift and there was no
comics and so I remember I dropped the
mozzarella sticks or something the onion
rings or whatever and then there's no
comic and they go hey you want to go up
it's like absolutely and so that I and I
forgot that I dropped this these you
know mozzarella sticks or whatever and
so I went on stage and there was a vent
by the stage it was by the kitchen and
so I'm on stage and it's like there's
nobody there so I'm doing a long set I'm
doing like 12 minutes 13 minutes and all
of a sudden smoke just starts bellowing
through the club because I'd left those
mozzarella sticks in there
oh did somebody order the mozzarella
sticks yeah you know that kind of thing
we made a big funny and I'm running off
stage fire extinguisher it was a fun way
to close I'll tell you fire extinguisher
well you know you grabbed it just in
case you know what's happening oh okay
okay
here's my prop I had to have a prop you
know yeah
yeah you know
that is a new one oh my gosh yeah yeah
it's uh it's a go ahead Yoshi the move
to LA
what was it a comedic move or was it
more of a personal move and any advice
for comedians thinking about moving to
like different scenes
yeah um we uh my girl's a comic as well
the Obama and some weird you know comedy
couple and stuff so it's uh every day
all day comedy and all that so you know
during the pandemic I felt like
um you know I just needed a change uh I
wasn't sure what was happening with New
York
um you know Dangerfield's one of my
favorite clubs and they closed that kind
of you know that was a weird one and so
it just felt like the scene was kind of
not sure what it was doing and then you
know we'd always just wanted to come out
here we both write scripts and things
like that and so we just felt like we
both done New York we you know we did we
passed all the clubs you know we got on
TV all the stuff so it was like let's
try something bigger and uh I felt like
La is a good place to be when you have
that New York kind of foundation you
know because I mean we really when
you're in New York Comic you stand out
up here because some some girls like hey
I'm a model slash comedian and then you
go on stage and just smoke them off the
stage because you know we're warriors in
New York and so it's uh you know so you
come with a lot of stand-up artillery if
you will but uh so yeah it was part of
that and then just you know that is
something about the desert and the
beaches and the mountains I I love all
that stuff so you know a little bit
personal in the nature and all that but
one thing I like about La is like New
York I would crush all the time and
nobody be in the crowd out here you do
five minutes and like somebody's like
hey I work at Warner Brothers would you
like to have a coffee you know like
there's a lot of Industry circulating
you know in the clubs which I don't see
a lot of that in New York where I feel
like you know it's like you crush and
you hope the person that books you sees
it the well-known industry or whatever
so I don't know there's a lot of that I
just kind of want to be around more of
the Showbiz stuff in New York it's like
but New York is where you become a great
comic I feel like all the guys we
idolize all the
you know they all you know they all
started New York you know they would
tell all those guys you know so it's
like New York makes you a strong comic
but I think sometimes it's good to you
know just leave the nest a little yeah
and just kind of you know I didn't want
to just be a club comic because I feel
like you know that happens a lot where
you could just make your living as a a
City Comic and you make you know decent
living you know you make you know a
couple hundred bucks maybe 600 bucks
whatever here on the weekend you know
and you kind of get comfortable and so I
kind of wanted to go somewhere where not
everybody you know no not everybody did
you know people don't all know me and I
can kind of you know just make a fresh
start you know and so uh yeah it just
kind of doesn't stand out
yeah it's like a cheers you wanted to go
to a different bar yeah
yeah
I want to be different you know and I
stand out out here so it's kind of great
everybody knew me in New York it's like
all right time to go I gotta get out of
here yeah do you think Comics even need
to move to like a New York or La anymore
that's interesting question
um
it depends it depends what your in-game
is really but yeah if you have a you
know ultimately if you if you have a fan
now if you've cultivated
[Laughter]
this whole live stream has been
hilarious
[Laughter]
we just lost Dustin
of all the times for my internet to be
acting up right now yeah this is
hilarious he doesn't he's not like on
the 45 minute Zoom plan is he is that
what happened there we are yeah we're
having a crazy Tech day nah this is
great now this keeps it exciting yeah
I'm back I'm back
um yeah what was the question uh fan
base oh yeah if you yeah I think you
could live like like Nate would Nate did
it right you know like he got like you
know enough exposure and road work and
presence that he could live anywhere and
so he chose Nashville and uh you know
but there's different scenes for sure I
mean you can go to Austin and just be a
comic Probably and you know industry as
long as industry is coming out I guess
it's it doesn't matter or if that maybe
that's not your goal maybe your goal is
just to work the road and not be seen
But if you want to be seen I think
there's more industry in places like
Austin Chicago Atlanta there's different
you know they're going around they
didn't used to it used to just be like
just for last was in New York or L.A you
know now those those things go to
different cities and so I think it's
definitely changed you know more than it
used to be
Michelle said it looks like you need to
move to a place that has internet that's
hilarious
really I go out once oh shut up after
all the technical difficulties you're
the one that's been after making fun of
Yoshi for like six minutes and then and
this is what I get yeah okay all right
sorry we had a Mudslide it's it's La God
knows what happened
you know how it is they are they're
going in they're going in hard
well I I uh
[Laughter]
yeah LeBron left that's where you live
all right
you want to go after Michelle it's weird
when you want to go out for somebody you
can't see them
is they can't respond so you can say
whatever you want exactly yeah I love it
I love it
I I posted on our Facebook group uh that
you were coming on the show and people
posted some questions for you
that uh we can get into uh the the first
one is from uh Phil ketron who said
with all the social media available what
is your opinion on the best use slash
spend money on to promote yourself
interesting
um
yeah I don't know I think I'm old school
um I say album first I thought I I knew
you were gonna say this that he's old
school yeah okay shut up you know you
didn't know that no he said old school
not old Yoshi be nice come on okay
you know you the way you've sort of
described your comedy history of like
the bill Burrs the potatoes like it's
just very obvious and haven't seen you
on stage it's very obvious you have an
old school like mentality the way that
you think about comedy and the way you
think about killing on stage yeah well I
mean if you don't think about killing
you're not a comic let's just put that
out there
okay just go away like be an experience
artist or something be a poet okay if
you don't think about crushing and being
the best comic in the room you're in the
wrong business yeah so there's that if I
say old school I just mean like I don't
know it's like we all of us all the guys
you respect they did albums first then
they did this then they did late night
then they did specials and they did
whatever I mean just know I don't know I
think if you're gonna put money into
social media I mean you can you can get
marketers and things and get your tick
tocks up and stuff like that and that
might help you if you have the act for
that
you know I mean a guy like me I think
people want to you know they want to
come out to the club and see me I don't
think they necessarily want to watch I
really resisted the whole Clips thing I
mean that seems to be where everything's
headed I just felt like it was uh you
know it's like you're putting your act
out there you know number one you're
just putting you're just giving you're
just giving people good premises to play
with you know when you're putting your
stand up out there every day I mean
there's you know so that that bothers me
a little bit you know where I feel
people could just look at your clip and
go oh let me rewrote it when we reword
this joke and so I resisted that I
resisted what you guys do with the clips
and stuff and uh for a long time and
then I felt like I scrubbed the internet
with my sets because I didn't just I
wanted if you wanted to see me then come
see me live you can hear me on a podcast
you'll get a sense of who I am and then
I have albums that are out I have two
albums out and comedy records you can
listen to those but yeah I don't know I
think that I think the album's a good
way to go I mean I don't know if you
guys have done that have you done an
album or anything but I feel like you
know it's a smart way I mean during the
pandemic I put on an album on zoom and
uh I got it on Sirius and that was a big
deal for me because it was like I found
a way to kind of make a living through
technology which was an old school by
the way Yoshi
I did an internet album and I got it on
serious and I made pretty good money off
of it because I was trying to be
Innovative I was like because I can't be
old school I can't go to the clubs right
now so it was a way for me to make money
off of it but I think there's different
ways I don't know if there's a right way
to answer that because it's like I don't
know your act I think some people's act
might be perfect for social media and
put your money into it because I mean
you guys know that I mean Yoshi is are
you like a social media manager or
something I feel like you have some tech
job yeah
that's a side hustle I used to have a
tech job but but I'm very much like you
is that I'm terrible at marketing myself
marketing myself but yeah
he's projecting unto you now Dustin I'm
saying that I'm terrible at marketing
myself so like I believe like what you
mentioned around the clips
I've resisted clips for okay I'd rather
just be in the clubs because like that's
where I wanna I want people to come see
me because I believe I'm a performer
that's worth seeing and paying money for
absolutely so I mean but I think to your
point like everyone has a different path
and yeah definitely I just think the
short clips
you know as I look at like you know
people who are younger and like 20 year
olds that's just what they're targeted
in terms of how they think of comedy
comedy to them now is a short clips
comedy is like two three minutes max 30
seconds of just oh that was funny great
next day that was funny great next thing
right and so I think there's just an
element of you know you've been doing
comedy for a while now and I think as as
you get farther into this you're like
you want a body of work and I think I'm
more of like here's the body of work and
I want you to see it versus here's 18
seconds of a premise that I thought
about that has a great video attached to
it and now I get 40 000 views but it's
like that 40 000 views could might get
you paid work
yeah you're right you're right and you
said something
um great video footage which that isn't
always the case that's always funny when
you see somebody just do it so
wobbly ass video and then like the
captions and stuff but yeah I mean with
my dry bar you know we cut some clips
out and I think it drove people to the
drive bars and stuff so yeah I think you
use it as much as you can I don't think
there's a right or wrong answer oh
comics new Comics like it's just you
know ultimately it's about jokes and
storytelling and so as long as you're
doing that right and you're being
authentic to yourself
you know I think that's enough and you
you know but you can put money into
people marketing yourself you know I
know you know the bigger guys do that
they don't have time to do it so they
have social media managers and stuff a
lot of these big Comics you think
they're responding to you they're not it
just said some some kid named Daryl
who's 19.
no
[Laughter]
I mean there's a lot of that happening
so you know if you got the money for
that why not if I you know if I could
afford it I would
for sure yeah I think Chris Chris
DiStefano just like got off social media
and he CR like and he has like a manager
now social media sure like team and
stuff and he created that with like just
so much less anxiety and more just he
could focus on what matters most and
stuff but like yeah younger Comics just
trying to figure out how to tell a joke
are now trying to figure out how to get
a crowd work clip in their three-minute
Open Mic set at the coffee shop that
they can post I hope to go viral so then
they can sell out a venue and bomb for
an hour and lose every fan they had like
at a certain point it's like yeah do
Clips if you have something worth seeing
like yeah you know you go viral and then
what or you post this clip are you gonna
be proud of that in two years like
that's like that's very old thinking
Joel I like it
yo speaking of those what is what is
your opinion on notes on stage Dustin
let's get to the bottom of this
okay I didn't open mic
I here's the deal
um I don't think you should ever lift
the paper off the stool I don't think
you should ever look at your phone I
think it I think it's okay a lot of big
Comics do this I do it when I headline
sometimes because I'm trying to figure
out you make sure I get everything out
so I think if you place something on the
stool like a large index card or
something and you have your you have
your premises or you have the stuff you
want to go into and you do one of these
I think it's okay but if you're pulling
it out I'm asking guys you know they're
just like all right let me let me do
this like you know none of that but if
you want to glance that's fine you know
I don't think it's a big deal if you
glance but you they the audience
shouldn't be aware of it it should be
very nonchalant you shouldn't make it a
big deal I mean Janine Garofalo did a
special on HBO and her whole thing she's
looking through the her notebook and
stuff so there's been people at high
levels that have done it but I think
it's best to just you know glance kind
of look down you know just not make a
big deal about it
because bands do that they have their
set list on the ground and stuff I
remember one time somebody told me that
I was playing a college for the first
time and I was like I don't know if I
can remember all this material and
they're like well you know bands like
you know they put like their their set
list they tape it to the ground and the
guy was like you should do that and I
was like okay man and so I remember I
was my first college I was so excited
and then I got so like you know before
the show started I taped all these like
you know notes on the on the on the
ground but I'm kind of nearsighted and I
have horrible handwriting so I'm on
stage and I'm trying to go and I just
and I I'm looking down I'm trying to
make it nonchalant
what if
what you know so I can't read it and I'm
struggling to read it and then I can't
see it it was a disaster
horrible idea so sometimes it doesn't
work out so I I've moved to the stool in
the index card so
all right
I just saw uh who's somebody special I I
saw
paper on the table and on the floor
s'mores some more specials oh okay yeah
all right yeah I mean your point to your
point it was just like it wasn't a
it wasn't like pick it up kind of thing
she just kind of glanced at it and then
went back to her set because I think she
just like she got so much laughs and she
was like all right let me take a break
and then let me look and then get right
back into it to your point yeah and it
depends how much new stuff you're going
to be doing because it's like like I
burned all this material with the dry
bar so my goal now I'm going out with
Nate going out on my own and it's like I
want to do new stuff because I know a
lot of these people are going to have
seen my you know whatever so you know if
you have a lot of new stuff I mean I
think it's okay but it's it's you know
I've seen guys I've seen guys have notes
they don't do one new joke it's like why
did you make a big deal about the notes
you could do anything new I've seen it
all the time like they act like it's new
they're like uh let me do this new joke
that I did six years ago
we're not doing new stuff
that that happens a lot so make sure at
least it's new if you're gonna do that
yeah Bobby benavidez has asked in our
Facebook group too and you talk about
you burning your material he asked when
should you retire jokes are there jokes
used in your special you'll continue to
use or should they stop after you've uh
recorded them
well I I used him a little bit with my
albums because I felt like I hadn't done
it I hadn't done a mod video yet or
special or anything so I did use them a
little bit
um you know but uh yeah I'm Really Gonna
not do them anymore like that's my goal
is to I have some stuff I really want to
get into so I think once you get it out
there once it's been on something you
know once it's been you've done a late
night or a you know hopefully a special
or whatever you know I think that's you
know I think that's when you're supposed
to I don't know I mean because some
jokes and I get mad when jokes still
work you know what I mean you got a joke
that you wrote you know seven years ago
why are you still working I go I don't
want to use you Roy
yeah I always get mad at jokes I got
jokes I was like thank God you know it's
like I just can't do them anymore
because I just I feel like they're way
too old but yeah I think that's what it
is get it on something leave it
somewhere it needs to live somewhere
once your jokes live somewhere I think
in you know and I don't think you know I
don't know I'd rather live on a special
than on a clip but you know that's just
my opinion
really hit the p on that clip these
clips now my first rodeo gig but hey
these kids and their Clips out here old
school clip comedy yeah I mean I'm in
that I'm in that transition right now of
like writing new material after well I
self-produced a special on my 10-year
anniversary and then whenever the dry
bar comes out like that all that
material will be there so I'm trying to
write new stuff but it is like if it
works it's like so hard to get out of
that safe zone of like oh well this joke
didn't work let me go to this joke from
four years ago that I know will work and
you can kind of get caught in that rut
so I'm kind of in that like I'm trying
to get The Bravery back to go out on a
limb
yeah
so when did you do your dry bar about a
year ago you said
like a year and a half now maybe wow
yeah I was
yeah I did it was during the pandemic
yeah okay I did mine last May so it was
about almost a year yeah that's a lot of
anxiety um my girl did Colbert and it
was like a year before they released her
Colbert so it's like wow it's just it's
interesting it's like there's so much
anxiety with that you know it's like
people just you know it's like ah it's a
comic whatever that we'll just release
it whenever you know so it's like like I
knew a guy uh two years they didn't and
they just released it like like a month
ago his dry bar and stuff so yeah that's
a I know what you're feeling and I think
don't release it when it feels like it's
right for you know they have a lot of
white guys so yeah
in this clump of too many white guys so
they're they're trying to spread you out
more like light bar white bar
[Music]
oh my God I'm never coming back they're
all watching somewhere
especially me like I look like a Mormon
poster child they're like they're saving
me for a holiday
for sure I think I have a missionary
look just a companion look just like you
yeah
um so yeah so get it on something good
you know your material deserves to be on
something good so once it's on don't
feel bad about doing something old if
you're making a living off of it you
know because it's our tools you know
we're like plumbers like you know
sometimes your closer is your wrench and
your thing and you use it it's like you
know it's what you can make a living off
of and it's hard to come up with jokes
that always work so you know I think
it's but it's important to eventually
retire you know I don't know if you ever
saw that did you ever see that interview
where it was like it was Seinfeld Louis
CK and Chris Rock and they were talking
uh comedy and it was like you could tell
like Seinfeld was like what do you mean
write a new act every year and you know
and Chris Rock and Louie were like nah
man that's that's what you're supposed
to do and you could tell like you know
something Phil was kind of like nah man
I do the same jokes and you're like yeah
but you know it was it was a funny
moment between kind of the old school
comic and then two guys that are just
trying to like you know generate new and
new material and different fan bases so
yeah it was interesting
yeah it is different yes
now he does new stuff but I think at
that time he was just doing that same
Act
but yeah I did my ACT way too long so
I'm excited to do news I'm excited to
kind of not to cut not bomb but I'm
excited to you know figure it out you
know I think that's Comics sometimes get
too caught up in like oh my God I you
know let me is this gonna work I mean
you just kind of you know you force
yourself to do it you know it's like uh
athletes who beat teams are not supposed
to be you know you find it you know you
find a way for this stuff to work even
when it's new just gotta come out of
heart
yeah it's just starting over it's like
spent 10 years getting one set and now
you're like oh boy yeah now the fun
begins it's part it's the job though I
mean it looks like it's in relationship
yeah yeah in a relationship you're like
all right here we go
start over we're gonna listen to stuff
about her mom again you know or whatever
yeah and that's what I had like a lot of
marriage stuff trying to figure out what
else is there like my special was called
the trophy husband had like a lot of
marriage stuff I was like well what else
do I want to talk about it's like
finding she's trying to find a whole new
that is hard yeah
because it is hard trying to find you
know I think you just kind of like
just go off of a joke that's new that's
working and like make that your base you
know I mean I don't think it has to you
know so much thought has to be into like
what am I gonna what's my identity now
you know what I mean I think it's more
like you have that one joke that maybe
works that you haven't used and like and
then just kind of bounce off that joke
and milk that one as long as you can
into other bits that are similar that's
what I'm doing right now it's like I'm
just trying to take one joke that I know
works that I haven't put anywhere and
then just right around that joke and
just like you know take that joke a
little further you know
so that's just one I don't know that's I
think that's a good way to do it don't
put so much thought into it you know
yeah very helpful
um
let's see maybe like one or two more
we're coming up on the hour here with
our technical difficulties
that um really can't get internet over
here
[Laughter]
um Drew beakler asked what kind of
adjustments did you make going from city
road work spots to opening for Nate and
TJ
um well Nate obviously is uh very family
friendly
um so there was quite a contrast those
guys yeah it was uh you know definitely
some adjustment
um there
um you know his last his special
Tennessee kid I think it was uh or the
one after that average American or
something was uh rated G so
um you know that's that's crazy and uh
you know I mean I mean it's right there
with like you know like just rated G
movies like you see it like he comes he
comes up yeah
wow yeah but and it's so and then you go
into these shows and these shows are
ridiculous you know they're just like I
mean I'm blessed to be a part of these
shows you know they're Arenas and
theaters and but that but the beauty of
it is it's like you know you'll see
families there seeing stand up together
so it's like the dad can bring the kids
and the grandma you know it's phenomenal
it's like Nana and the two kids and
everybody so
you know knowing that that was what I
had to adapt to
um I found a way to kind of get rid of
the edge in certain things and still
talk about stuff like like I can talk
about drugs if I come from the
perspective of you know I'm a recovering
addict and so I'm not sitting there
going hey I dropped some you know Somali
and I partied I could be like yeah you
know I used to have a problem and
whatever and I find a way to talk about
the same things I was talking about but
from a different angle you know a way
that's a little more wholesome a little
more you know thoughtful or whatever so
that's some of my material I would do it
that way I would just come at it from a
more mature perspective that wasn't
offensive to kids or whatever but uh but
yeah and then you know Nate says Nate's
cool he'll be like look dude just don't
say the f word and don't talk about sex
and you could be edgy you know and so
you know there's about eight of us that
open forum and it's like you know a lot
of us keep our Edge we just don't you
know go down the road that's gonna
offend anybody but with TJ anything goes
you know I mean I could I could get on
stage naked he wouldn't care so yeah
it's like it's like whatever dude you
know have fun you know whatever so it's
kind of a nice release because with Nate
it's like I keep hitting check and I
play by the rules and whatever but uh
and then with you know then I'll do a
gig right after that with TJ or whatever
and he's like yeah just kind of go wild
or whatever but I'm leaning towards kind
of being cleaner because I feel like the
Market's bigger you know and it's like
and then you get the fan base is bigger
and uh yeah it's just you know we get
bad habits as City Comics sometimes it's
like you know it's like a lot of late
shows and a lot of you know different
things and we just feel like we have to
say you know curse and stuff and and
sometimes you do you know a joke you
know needs it sometimes but a lot of
times it's just you know lazy riding you
know so we don't always need to be dirty
and we don't always and I think
blue you have to be gifted to be blue
you know and I think a lot I see a lot
of young Comics that don't have the
talent to be so blue like Richard Pryor
could be blue because he was so freaking
talented he could pull it off and he
pulled off clean when he first started
so it's like but sometimes I think it
takes it takes a really good performer
to get an audience to get on board with
you when you're talking about you know
going down on somebody or whatever you
know whatever it is you're doing so it's
like I think you need to be you know
good at that I I always say start
cleaning and then maybe head there if
that's where your comedy takes you but
but I think clean's the way to go I
really do more money man
[Laughter]
not that life
yeah well and the goal is to get on TV
like late night and all that stuff it's
like you know just just to prepare I
mean you should think bigger that's all
right I think bigger that mindset seems
to be a big part of your comedy journey
of like challenging yourself getting at
a comfort zone continue to push forward
and creating big goals that seems to be
a big part of what you've done I think
so you know and uh I think that's it's
never too late you know that's the best
thing about comedy it's like it's not
like an athlete like you could you could
do this I mean I saw Rickles in his 80s
and stuff and just crushing you know so
it's like that's the thing about comedy
we can just do this forever you know you
can reinvent yourself you can like
change your act you can be you know it's
that's what's exciting about it so keep
keep dreaming keep going bigger you know
keep thinking you know I can do
something and you know not think that
you're you know you've missed out on
anything because I don't think it's ever
you're ever too old to start this you're
never too young to hit like it just you
know any anybody can hit this thing I
mean I remember you know I used to this
is one I used to run a show and this kid
would would go on stage and he called
himself the teenage comic and I was like
dude I go that's so corny go stop saying
that and uh that was Pete Davidson and
so he was 50 years old
wow and I was like that's so corny and I
love that I got to tell him he was corny
I was like this is so corny dude you're
not gonna be 15 forever like stop
calling yourself that and I remember
that was one night and he stopped doing
it and like of course he became a star
because of me now
I'm taking all the credits all the
credit every single bit of it but but
you know so anyway he was a little child
and he you know he hit so you know but
I've never known this business yeah I
think that is a good perspective because
even someone like and just will say Nate
because it's someone we've been talking
about but it's like people see him now
and they're like oh lucky him it's like
he's in his 40s like yeah it's not like
he woke up and this happened like you
know like a lot of these Comics that are
famous now like most of them aren't Pete
Davidson where they just blew up in like
at 20.
[Laughter]
at least middle school but uh
yeah I think the older you get the more
interesting you get I mean George Carlin
was his best work you know is when he
hit his stride you know his 50s and
stuff so yeah I mean you just have more
to say you live a life so you know I
think it's uh that's what makes these
guys interesting I mean you see Brett
Chrysler he's still taking his shirt off
you know I mean he doesn't care so yeah
I'm always amazed by that I was like
really dude hitting 40 still taking your
shirt off good for you man
you can do whatever you do whatever you
want nobody you know do whatever
it's uh yeah it's it's Lawless
whatever
um I was gonna ask
you started like I met you on like the
festival scene what do you think about
comics and getting which festival do you
remember
[Music]
um I got I got that second place trophy
somewhere
[Laughter]
okay at a
at us like I think oh nice okay your
soda and then maybe I didn't do too many
of those I think it was Vegas that's
probably where I met you or it was
another casino yeah
okay yeah so what do you think about
like any advice for Comics thinking
about sort of just the festival route or
like the competition route as well
um I think
um I'm kind of edging myself out of it
but I think it's important to do it uh
depending on what you have going on in
your life and
um depending on you know if you're not
touring or working with people or if
you're not past at clubs or if you're
not you know working on something I
think these are great ways to kind of
get exposure and meet other comedians
who might help you get work and stuff so
yeah I love the World Series I feel like
uh it was good for me to be because I
was always bad at competition stuff so
it it kind of helped me figure out how
to do that and how to like figure it out
and whatever and and be okay under
pressure and stuff like that so I think
it's it's good I mean sometimes you know
I
don't like the atmosphere that contests
can create you know I remember I some
dude was treat me like it was some
basketball playoff game or something I
was like dude man you can't do this like
get in my head and stuff I was like dude
go we're artists man calm down
he's trying to like psych me out so
there was a little bit of that in a
competition Vibe but but I think it's
good I think it's good to push yourself
and you know figure out a way to kind of
just you know just do you just gotta do
stuff I mean people you know they're not
going to get to if you're not if you're
not a social media [__] then you got to
go out and do other stuff because you
gotta you gotta get seen so whatever it
is you can do and uh it's just good to
try to you know do stuff so I think it's
I think it's good and the the uh the
networking is is great and I think it's
it's important to meet comics and meet
industry and and talk to people and you
know definitely do it when you're ready
at least have a good seven ten minutes
you know don't just do it out of nowhere
an open mic kind of thing I mean you
know get your bearings a little bit
before or you're just you're you know
you'll just go to fly to Vegas for four
minutes and you know cry all the way
home so you know you wanna you wanna
you don't want to do that so
let's come in with a strategy to win
yeah
well yeah as a as as we uh land the
plane do you have any like favorite
closing advice for uh comedians
closing advice uh you know just uh enjoy
the ride write every day if you can
um you know try to be different try to
write you know something that maybe a
lot of people aren't talking about you
know try to stand out really and then uh
yeah just uh be kind you know get to
know a lot of comics like be friends
with Comics don't be weird and those
relationships let me tell you they come
back they'll hurt you and they'll come
back and help you you know I was nice to
guys and now they're coming back and
helping me and so you know create a good
environment for yourself a good you know
kind of Comedy Foxhole of guys and girls
you take care of and stuff I think
that's important this is kind of like
look out for each other because there's
only there's not that many people doing
this and so it's like it's a very Niche
kind of thing so it's like you know
reach out to people that are doing it
and you know kind of create your own
scene of good people and be kind and
take care of each other you know
other shows all that stuff you know
well please promote uh your dry bar
special is out now check it out check it
out anything else top 10 baby we're
doing good
doing good we're doing good
yeah
so uh it's craky pants my girl helped me
named it because apparently I'm cranky
in the morning and uh
and the set kind of made sense because
I'm because I'm on stage like it's a you
know like come on people what's wrong
with you that kind of vibe that New York
Vibe so it's like it comes off kind of
cranky in Provo but um yeah you could go
to dry go to the promo code or whatever
and put in D Chaffin c-h-a-f-i-n uh all
caps and you get a free month of dry bar
so you can watch my special watch some
other specials some good good guys on
there if you want to check that out but
yeah check it out you can uh Dustin's
vinyl it's a show I do on Twitch we talk
about records and stuff I collect vinyl
records all over the country and stuff
so we talk about that so that's kind of
a fun show yeah podcast as well
kaboom blue Chapin thank you so much for
um hanging out with us today thanks for
having me it was fun man all right I
hope you find that right now
I am I'm finding Mont Blanca get better
internet that's my goal
s
live as well
[Laughter]
you guys are great have me on any time
if you got you know it's like for sure
bro you can't make it Jeselnik or
somebody can't make it let me know
we got you we love we love meeting
Comics that love uh helping Comics so um
thank you for sharing your time with us
I mean we might go we might need to do
the same thing Justin's doing with that
Dustin vinyl and just stick it in the
back right it's a good idea you know
it's running a little light lights up
yeah
yeah we'll uh we'll work on getting a
working microphone first and then we'll
worry about signs
[Laughter]
guys guys
look it went out it went out
thank you Dustin we'll see you all next
week that was fun